MARC MARON: I don't wanna
be negative, but...
I don't think anything's
ever gonna get better
ever again.
♪ (ROCK MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
And don't misunderstand me,
I have no hope.
I think if you have hope,
what are you, fucking seven?
Like, if you really think
a flying Jew
is gonna come back
and make everything okay,
isn't that, like,
mental illness?
You think you're
a better man than me
'cause you have human kids?
I have three cats
that I love.
And in the best case
scenario,
I'm gonna have to
have them all killed.
I'm gonna have to kill
my friends.
And I knew it going in,
that's how big my heart is.
Let me get serious.
I know a lot of you know
that during COVID,
my girlfriend passed away.
She did. Passed away, and it
was the most horrible thing
that's ever happened to me,
and I'm sure to her.
The truth is, like,
I'm a guy who talks
about his life.
So, I wasn't clear
how that was gonna go,
how am I gonna talk
about that?
But then I thought, "Well,
maybe, how about a TED Talk?"
I just have to change
my posture a little bit.
Everyone dies.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I'm gonna die.
You're gonna die.
We all die.
I'm Marc Maron.
I'm a comedian.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS, CLAPS)
♪ (ELECTRIC GUITAR PLAYS) ♪